it's a pleasure to be joined today by
Richard McGowan who is professor at the
Carroll school at Boston College we are
going to be talking about sin taxes we
are going to be talking in part two of
our interview about the recent Supreme
Court decision that will greatly expand
sports gambling and sports betting on
sports Richard thank you so much for
joining me today great to be with you so
let's start sort of broadly I mean when
we are talking about activity that the
government has identified as problematic
in some way or activity that the
government wants to curb or encourage
people not to participate in one
possibility is criminalization another
is regulation which includes taxation
can you give a sort of a general sense
of what the issues at play are when an
activity has been identified that we
want to curb and sort of what
possibilities there are and how we want
to manage that well let's just first
list the traditional what we would call
sin industries and I had a couple of new
ones now traditionally it started out
without all because in the United States
clearly the first thing that was taxed
was was alcohol and of course we had the
whiskey rebellion from that then then we
had cigarettes and then finally you had
gambling in its own little worm now
ironically we're adding marijuana and in
lots of locations right now soda is
becoming almost a sin industry so you
have you've got things that the
government wants there's using and
there's there's there's at least two and
then sometimes three goals the
government wants once one is obviously
to raise revenue so all these activities
you can tax and I always say it's
painless revenue because in other words
people feel somewhat guilty doing them
so therefore when the government taxes
you you don't you don't complain as much
about it the other thing is clearly you
also and this is where the government
gets it something a little bit of
contrariness the government wants you to
do they want to dissuade you from doing
the activity so they're making money
from you but they want you this they
don't want you to do the activity and
then in lots of the cases we
especially with alcohol and gambling and
marijuana you have what they want to
discourage the black market and so
there's where that there's usually three
things involved I'm not a sort of at a
base level like at a philosophical level
against the taxation or raising of
revenue by governments in these ways but
it's hard for me to get past the reality
that speeding tickets for example which
is a sort of different thing presumably
the idea is the police want you to obey
the law and that's why if you exceed the
speed limit you risk getting pulled over
and you get a ticket and presumably if
that happens next time you might be
careful you might not speed but the
police departments do become reliant on
that revenue so on the one hand it's
purportedly a mechanism to get people to
behave the way that the government or
police want them to behave but at the
same time if everybody did it police
would have a really hard time funding
their operations and there's a sort of
similar dynamic when it comes to some of
these sin taxes how should we interpret
that in other words does the government
really want to dissuade people from
doing these things well for instance for
years the government would raise the
excise tax on cigarette just enough that
they would make more revenue look
clearly but clearly they didn't raise it
enough to dissuade people and it took
the whole second hand smoking situation
where people said the non-smokers
following so I have rights
not the smell of smoking that's what
government didn't said you know well
let's raise the tax is really high and
that's really now trying to discourage
people from smoking so you're right
there for instance in the alcohol
industry you could you really know that
it's interesting in in the vast vast
majority of states beer is taxed at a
much much lesson rate than distilled
spirits and somehow there it's
interesting sometimes the government
also declares the type of activity that
they actually want you to do even if it
is a sin industry so clearly in most
states the government would prefer you
to to drink beer and not distilled
spirits and wine is considered in
between and let's look at gambling the
government has a monopoly on lotteries
and therefore really really what they
really would prefer you to do is to
spend your money on lotteries if you
have casinos in the state you only tax
them at most between 25 percent so
clearly the gambling dollar from the
government's point of view is better
much better and that notice the
government does try to make you feel
good about betting the lottery even
though it's a horrible bit when we talk
about something like the lottery or
maybe with alcohol or with any when it
with any of these is there a way that or
let me rephrase it in a different way if
the government truly wanted to just get
people to stop doing this all together
what would actually be the action that
they would do would it be setting the
tax so high that it would no longer be a
viable business would it be full-out
criminalization even though we know that
with many of these vices it just creates
a black market it doesn't actually get
people to stop like if the government
rather than raising revenue wanted to
actually stop people from engaging in
this activity what would be the most
effective means of achieving that I mean
the problem with raising the tax up to
high is the very thing you just
mentioned a minute ago
is it your court created a black market
for instance in with cigarettes it
became whenever let's let's go back 50
years David and it's really kind of
interesting we have back 50 years ago
almost 40 percent of the adult
population smoked cigarettes and you had
one state with the lottery New Hampshire
then you had one state with casino
gambling and now 50 years later or 55
years later to be exact
you now have 28 states with some form of
casino gambling 48 states have some kind
of the lottery and notice gambling has
been accepted cigarettes have not been
accepted so what you're getting out
there is kind of government when the
government goes after us in does it make
it culturally on not viable anymore so
that's the interesting thing with
cigarettes I mean they they got tax and
it's almost as if the government said
alright let's really tax them now put it
into it and that way we'll save what
wants health care but with gambling
we're not going to do that and
so it's so why gambling is socially
acceptable for the government versus
cigarettes but in general I would say
it's going to be taxes but I also say
the government has two for instance with
cigarettes they could start doing a lot
more on in five cigarettes I guarantee
you they are not going to sponsor
anti-gambling ads you've worked as a
consultant to help States
look at how they want to regulate casino
and and lottery operations without
obviously sharing private or you know
sensitive information for us what are
the sort of dynamics of those
discussions with states in other words
is the attitude of the states when
they're speaking candidly with you if
indeed they are and I don't know if they
will even speak candidly with you do
they say we don't really think that this
is a good thing but we're going to allow
it for revenue purposes or sort of like
what's what's their attitude when they
are having these discussions well I
think you just know no one is ever gonna
be saying I'm Pro gambling what you say
is people are doing it we'd like to we
like to put the black market or the or
the organized-crime out of the business
so therefore let's let's let's raise the
let's get the revenue and maybe we can
do some good with the revenue as opposed
to what organized crime could do with
the revenue so it's give you an old
story and isn't but it's a very true
story when Massachusetts first started
its lottery how they set up their game
the daily number game they went and they
raided the bookies in the north end of
the Boston that's where all them where
all the bookies were found out how the
bookies set up their game gave a certain
amount they gave better odds in the
bookie and they put the bookies out of
business ironically that also forced the
organized crime into drugs so I would
probably your answer is most people are
saying how we deal with the addiction
issue with gambling at the same time
people are going to gamble so that's
that's that's gets the revenue and is
that the same sort of logic you would
apply to marijuana legalization
it's exactly the same lot the thing with
marijuana is
it's interesting once again it is the
same you'll want to raise the revenue
you're gonna probably try to discourage
too many people from doing it and at the
same time you want to put the black
market out so the big thing with
marijuana is what's the tax rate you're
going to put on so the people would
rather go buy from the state than from
from the organized crime let's pause
there we're speaking with Richard
McGowan who's a professor at the Carroll
school at Boston College we'll pick up
our conversation with him tomorrow we're
continuing our conversation with Richard
McGowan he is a professor in the Carroll
school at Boston College we've been
talking about sin taxes the taxation of
alcohol marijuana regulation etc and I
want to get now to the topic of sports
gambling we've had a recent Supreme
Court decision stemming from an appealed
case from New Jersey which is going to
make it easier and possible for sports
gambling to expand to many more states
so to start this conversation Richard
what if anything distinguishes sports
gambling from the other vices that we've
discussed it really isn't all that much
to be quite honest David it's the same
logic people are already doing it
there's lots of lots of people doing it
now there is one huge difference with
sports gambling and that is the vast
majority of people who sports gamble are
doing it online they do not go younger
and so it's not going to the local
bookie and things like that anymore
so again but the logic here is new
jersey decided they needed something
that would would make their casinos
unique in the northeast they wanted to
have casino gambling
so they what's the revenue issue then
obviously trying to put whatever the
black market online basically out of
business and then finally they're trying
to discourage consumption somewhat and
trying to comply with age limits and
things like that one there has been one
difference touted and I'm curious to get
your reaction as to whether it's sort of
a material practical difference of any
value which is that with sports gambling
you do have the possibility of
individuals who are sort of determining
the outcome possibly parts
in the bedding right whether it's
players or referees that might be
involved and of course that would be
against the law it would also be against
the rules of whatever league you're
participating in but it's something
conceivably that could happen which
seems like it is a different dynamic
than with some of these other vices
we're talking about but I guess my
question from a sort of conceptual
standpoint is does that really represent
a practical difference in how it should
be regulated well one of the things
obviously you're pointing through there
is that when you have sports betting you
really have to worry much more about the
integrity of the game I think with pro
sports the pro athletes are making so
much money they're probably not going to
that's not gonna be their enticement
referees let's face it the NBA have a
referee who did it yes and was fired
because of that so the NBA has that
clearly the organization that's got the
biggest stake in this and worrying about
it if the NCAA because you're paying you
we're not paying college athletes I mean
let's let's face it I mean they might be
getting the free scholarship and
education and things like that but
they're not being paid and so there's
really going to be how you try to keep
how the NCAA is going to handle this as
and the integrity of the game there it's
really gonna be a real problem and what
is the sort of dynamic in terms of
dealing with that I mean you make it
against the law you make it against the
policies of the organization you do that
stuff but it still sort of can happen
you would hope that you discover it when
it's happening but in terms of
preventing that is there anything really
beyond that that can be done well I mean
obviously the sports leagues it's
interesting the sports league I think
have the gall to be quite honest I think
I'll say the golf that they want a
percentage of the sports revenue that
the states are going to be taking in to
pay for integrity purposes which by the
way they already have to do anyway so I
think I think like the NFL and the NBA
and Major League Baseball have the gall
to say that they want a percentage of
the sports bet from from from the States
is outrageous as far as I'm concerned
but for the NCAA
have to really even now they're all
ready to tell cleats you can't bet if
you do you're gonna lose your
scholarships and things like that but I
think you're gonna have to do a lot lot
lot schools are going to have to spend a
lot more money worrying about the
integrity and who's going on campus and
in consulting with which it would be
trying to contact student athletes I'd
love to take a minute to talk a little
bit about one of the arguments that's
made often against the legalization of
both betting gambling betting on sports
and the lottery and that's an argument
which says that the activities of
particularly playing the lottery but
also to some degree gambling and betting
on sports are overwhelmingly being done
by people who actually don't really have
the money to lose and that that's a
particular argument when it comes to the
lottery that it preys on those who those
who actually are least equipped to lose
a few bucks here and there playing the
lottery and the sort of libertarian
argument or retort is often listen the
government is not your nanny the
government is going to try to raise its
revenue in the bet ways that at best
sees fit and that's that's sort of it
the counter to that often also is well
if it's not legal people will still be
doing the betting they're just going to
be doing it in sort of a black market
way but the truth is that black market
lotteries are not that big of a thing I
mean of course they exist but a state
sanctioned lottery is a very very
different thing where do you come down
sort of on that issue and really it's
more of a question of government power
and intervention right yes immediately
say with the laundry I think it's
probably true allow the instant tickets
where you see people scrapping tickets
and things like that there are certainly
people who should not be there and and
and the government one of the estimates
I've heard is that around 30 percent of
the players of lottery tickets by around
70 percent of the tickets so clearly the
government has
morale has a moral obligation to spend a
lot more money on compulsive gambling
and the problem that people have with
compulsive being with all right
again if the lotteries right now are
basically flat and so that's the other
reason why state governments are looking
at sports betting because sports betting
is clearly something it will be
brand-new in the area of sports betting
by the way only that is really a middle
class thing it is it you clearly for
instance the fantasy sports leagues
right now which by the way are going to
popping and being being trouble once
regular sports for family but they are
clearly middle class or upper middle
class phenomenon there are the people
who want to play those games so it
depends for instance it means like an
alcohol clearly the upper classes are
the ones that drink scotch
lower class people usually drink beer
and so there's a little bit of that
going on with gambling that there's
certain things certain gambling games go
for the lower classes and that's the
lottery there's no doubt about that
versus sports gambling would certainly
affect I mean I think that the age group
that would really be a lock would be
eighteen to twenty to thirty five maybe
males and gandu but will go on in
college campuses once you want you
legalize sports game do you think that
there should be a distinction made in
the law as these laws are developed
between in-person sports gambling and
online like is there enough of a
difference in the dynamics there that it
would make sense to regulate them as
sort of separately or differently I
would probably say you're 100 percent
because if you have to go in person it's
probably either going to be to a race
track which is what New Jersey wants
they want you to go the casinos or a
racetrack and they don't want to put it
online excuse the pun here but I think
Delaware's already raising the ante on
sports betting because they want to put
everything online and so now how do you
regulate sports gambling online and make
sure that you know that if you're saying
it 21 is the earliest age you can do it
how do you regulate that how do you have
you assure that people will will keep
their bets underwear although certain
ways you could probably
about what people are betting and how
much they're betting online just
probably one or more circumstances that
you found in person many we've been
speaking with Richard McGowan joining us
today from El Salvador's professor in
the Carroll school at Boston College
Richard thank you so much for talking to
us about this
it's great to be with you David